welcome to Tom Pappas come to Papa hey
everybody welcome to another edition of
come to Papa your favorite podcasts
among all forms of entertainment I hope
you're doing well I hope you're enjoying
your tuesday i hope you're enjoying this
the middle the right smack middle of
summer time i've been hearing from a lot
of you and a lot of you have been giving
me your updates filling up the kiddie
pool staying home canceling everything
that you have to do and I'm proud of you
I will be heading off to the Hamptons
myself next week on July thirtieth i'll
be performing at guildhall a beautiful
theater in East Hampton if you haven't
been to the Hamptons now you have a
reason now more than the Sun move in the
beach more than lobster rolls and
barbecues and good friends you now have
a legitimate reason to head to the
Hamptons that's July thirtieth at
guildhall today I'm going to bring you
an interview with the great Dana Carvey
that I just recorded I think you will
enjoy it he's an amazing amazing man and
as you sit and talk with him as I did
you start to realize how many times this
man this one person has made you laugh
over the years it's an incredible
incredible thing and I was very lucky to
sit down with him and I will play that
interview for you to tweet you will
enjoy I'm sure make sure you go to
iTunes a lot of you have been and I
thank you for it go to iTunes make sure
you subscribe to this podcast so can
come up on your phone or your laptop or
wherever you receive radio waves from
the universe
and more importantly leave a little
review and some stars so other people
will be that people at Apple will be
thinking oh that's right this is a nice
little podcast and people enjoy this
thing and then they'll spread it around
a little bit more and will allow to will
be able to have more people come into
our universe it's um I know it's a
little risky don't think that I'm going
to like them more than I like you I like
you best the original core of the
podcast these new people come in a will
welcome them up with a warrior with a
wary eye we will analyze them and see if
they're worthy of being part of come to
Papa community but yeah make sure you go
to make sure you go to iTunes leave a
review leave some stars and all will be
good I am heading off today to Lake
Tahoe where I will be performing a
private event for a lot of sports stars
I did the event last year for a company
called American Century it was so much
fun i got to hang out with David Wells
and Cris Collinsworth and a bunch of
really cool people I'm hoping that goes
all well today next week next tuesday
i'll be coming on my way to the Hamptons
I will be coming through New York City
to the village underground where I will
perform the live come to Papa at the
village on the ground at eight o'clock
next Tuesday that's the 26th where we
can come and you can see me with Bob de
Bono Dan Soder Rory Albanese dan Madame
in marina Franklin it's going to be a
great show as all the live shows are but
now I bring you an interview my
conversation with the great Dana Carvey
hello everybody another edition of come
to Papa your favorite radio show among
all the radio shows on this radio show
channel I'm very excited very excited
not because it's summer not because I'm
heading out to the Hamptons on July
thirtieth performing guildhall not a few
tickets still available a couple still
available but I'm very excited for my
guest today the great Dana Carvey hello
to you thank you so excited to have fun
for me because you know there's just it
is a fraternity and the end of the day
like if i say to you i did a one nighter
in st. Louis right and I didn't you know
you kind of kind of know what happened
we know and not many people know because
they just think hey but the headspace
like my wife can come with me now and
she's punched out on vacation she's
going all around st. Louis and museums
I'm just already take a nap I look at my
notes right you know I'm shoring up
energy so you understand that it's
different than traveling for fun do you
find it stressful when she comes with
you um cuz you're in the work mode and
she's like what what about dinner well
that there is a little bit of that
there's been times when she'll drag me
out of the hotel and we'll go out to
lunch and stuff and it'll be fine right
yeah we don't but she's pretty
independent that's good but it there is
a little bit of that that yeah yeah
because I know what you mean yeah I have
the same thing my wife gets it she was a
comedian before we had children and she
she gets it but she doesn't really get
that when you're in st. Louis you've got
a show that night anything you do to use
any amount of energy is just gonna make
the show a little worse yes I mean it as
much as like just let's go for a walk
down by the waterfront ya know and when
they want a sound check you know right
that's something one time they this was
in st. Louis actually so will you come
down the sound check at three thirty and
just talk into the mic for a second
right go back to your room
and I go that's just gonna take energy
cuz I'm gonna say hello to the crew so I
said why don't you take video with your
phone of you talking to the mic and then
email it to me so I don't do that but
yet especially uh yeah everything it
takes away from the show that's right
it's really funny I actually do sound
check yeah I kind of just flipped on it
because I would try and get out of it
all the time and it is so silly for
comedian to go up and just row and okay
yeah great we'll see you later you put
your shoes on your pants back on haven't
done yet but I fig but and then I
started to think you know what it's
probably good that I talked to one
person before the show well that's true
to get that sort of extroverted the
mindset going yeah yeah but I tended I'm
a people pleaser so maybe i would start
to be a little funny in the mic and
maybe i do a couple selfies and suddenly
it's 20 minutes and 25 minutes yeah and
you I never know because at this point
at some point I lie down I don't know if
I'm gonna fall asleep right I don't know
when that's going to hit me like this
would be a good time and it might be
right exactly when the sound check it
when I could be 20 minutes of almost
meditative but you know it shows that we
care I I don't like feeling weak and
tired on stage no one hundred percent ya
know you're trying to do the best you
can it to the man people just don't
realize like my cousin always say oh you
don't have a real job you go in there
you're up on stage for what an hour and
then the you're in san diego for all
that taxing I'm not doing anything in
San Diego kind of get over my notes i'm
looking at stuff for me with the big
obstacle and maybe you can help me i
have not been able to figure out when to
eat in all these years when cuz you so
you get up you have breakfast mm-hmm
then eat lunch like say you're 11 yeah
and you've got that long gap before
you're right age basically at
eight-thirty i totally agree and i'll
tell you a lot of times lately i'll do
it in half like even if i get salmon and
rice i try to eat well right I'll do
half of it 530 because I don't want to
be too full right I just put a cover on
it'll be kind of cold and then I'll
finish it afterwards but you're right
that is a constant problem if you don't
want to get too full right but you want
to have energy yeah you know
want to be like sleepy yeah I'm spitting
salmon on the front row but maybe this
will help you with your brother-in-law
about the headspace of being a stand-up
like like to me it's sort of like why
does the golfer get paid more than the
caddy right all the work is in here yeah
you and I if we could get paid the same
to rekha lon we know we'd love to rake
the lawn because one and one is to write
with us one on one could be three or
maybe five so that's yeah it's a weird
headspace a show day is just different
yeah the mem when you wake up and you
know you have a show it's gonna be
completely except maybe Jay Leno the
Pope of comedy I don't know Jay seems to
be the one who might be built so
different he yeah you ever seen him it
before show you ever been like a comedy
magic when he's gonna go on yeah yeah he
is eating yeah chewing on his way to the
stage right yeah yeah he said stuff at
the county but in the table backstage he
orders like yes I'm in a steak potato
he's just yeah and just plowing through
it as he's talking everybody telling
jokes Jay gotta go on okay flossing on
his way up he just says he's he's never
ease the same on violent storm in a
private jet before stage on stage after
the show he's in the exact same
headspace he's basically the Dalai Lama
comedy it's crazy yeah I don't know how
he does it ya think I like that's just
built differently you know I mean there
is an element of lie if you're gonna do
a set at your gonna say is I'm gonna be
onstage every single day right that
would help I've always been a little bit
um I would call it love hate but if the
show was cancelled I feel a little
relief it's kind of like members school
when school was canceled snow day it was
just something that's what comes over me
a little bit right but if I do it a lot
for in the olden days I would do a lot a
lot right now I do maybe five sets a
month where did you start off doing
stamou San Francisco Bay Area in San
Francisco holy city zoo and you went
there purely for standup yeah and you uh
and you went in and that at that time
that's when you're just feeling it out
you were do
a lot and going on the road a lot well
no it just started out slow in that the
club's really started being built you
know right in 79 yeah i was in college
so my first night i went to a little
dive in berkeley called the law
salamandra because I'd seen in the bloke
the paper that comedians were gonna be
there and I've only seen famous
comedians on television right few
friends in it came and we went we
watched and I took out a napkin starting
i did a Howard Cosell impression I could
i think i could do this and this one guy
came up and he was so energetic in so
freeform so while I put the napkin back
in my pocket and that was Robin Williams
well I didn't know I thought maybe
there's one in every town red you know
but then they said it's open mic at
eleven o'clock ten people and I just
went up on a whim really I kept going
from there with I think um right up
there with stage fright with anybody for
about three four years uh I still get it
but just yeah stage fright sweating like
how heavy heavy heavy heavy stage fright
really yeah horrible bombing really
horrible it's I never had that level of
it like I would get nervous but I
remember like it's just kind of that
thing where I almost thought I should
have it more like I would be more
talented if I had it like when you saw
those those stories of Bob Dylan not
being able to go up on stage yeah Bob
Dylan if this is doing something that
ham right I think he's aware of it
something else I read Valentin had
buckets in the wings or is that all we
emit and I mean I was playing the ice
house with my son's the other night and
um um I just was feeling really
comfortable I just thought to myself for
I want oh this is interesting yeah and I
had a perfectly fine set I mean in other
words all that anxiety and fear that's
kind of a waste I merely getting psyched
up yeah just abject terror right you
know that that's the long long tees of
this for me is how I don't know just how
connected you can be to the experience
writing the voice in the back of your
head giving yourself a report card was
very big back in the day yeah all that
joke sucked I'm not doing well I'm
losing them and
times as you do it and it can take 30
years sometimes that voice is almost
deadened and it's like a really great
feeling but then it comes back it can
come back on a whim without you even
realizing yeah I'm think you're this
confident guy now and then all of a
sudden you're on stage thinking what is
wrong with me why are these people even
doing here well how do you because I
asked bill burr this the other day that
so you're working on your act to shoot a
special right and if you're working on
it sometimes you're in a Hot Club and
and you're getting applause breaks and
it just and then you shoot the special
right and you're getting a nice audience
but with all the rigmarole you're
getting half right um and it's sort of
like swing and a Miss like that moment
because i'm editing it now and I can go
let's not do a close-up because I see I
see in my eyes where I go wow that used
to always get an applause break now I've
got cameras rolling and it got a huh
yeah and how do you the only thing I
could think of is to do a lot of
specials only way is I yeah it's that
I'm actually doing one on Saturday oh
really yeah well this is a perfect ah
perfect where are you shooting I was
trying to remind myself of it this
morning because I'm going to Cleveland
the hannah theater in Cleveland how many
square it's 500 seats perfect yeah
that's good 500 yeah I like that and
that city I always have good fans there
it's like a good feeling it's like this
vaudeville looking house but I literally
was thinking you have to go into these
remembering that you're doing a TV show
yeah this isn't a set yeah I'm gonna go
run it the comedy magic club tomorrow
I'll be then I'll run the whole hour and
now I got nervous and then that will be
really fun it'll pop like you said yeah
love it yeah jealous and I have to
remember when I go in on Saturday this
is a TV show so it probably won't go as
great at times maybe we'll maybe I'll
get lucky but if it doesn't you just
have to keep in mind that keep a smile
on your face and keep doing it yes this
is gonna cut together yeah in a show
that's going to be fine it's going to be
well okay yeah that bill burr's answer
was I just think to myself as long as
it's a fair like a like there's
10 and a one as long as it's a
middle-of-the-road representation of
what the act is right but don't think
it's going to levitate into this other
thing if it does it does yeah I mean
don't you didn't you feel I mean you've
recorded so many things but not only
specials but yeah but just in television
yeah filming whatever yeah at certain
moments that you think we're great
weren't as great and things you think
were came off awful there are better
than you thought yeah it seems like TV
kind of levels everything out in a way
yeah and I don't obviously people talk
to this can you really capture there's
something missing about television
televised stand up in the theater the
only time it feels a little close if
you're on Fallon because it's a
fifty-million-dollar thing they invented
where you know you're doing stand-up on
a talk show it seems like it works there
the myth but taking trying to make a TV
studio out of a theater right and make
it at the optical but this is other I'm
just dealing with it maybe you'll find
this interesting yes it is a TV show
right and they're in they might leave
any second so when you and I are the
comedy magic club we can meander and
take our time and do our preamble
because they're not going anywhere right
so I've been doing some editing yeah
based on some pretty smart notes from
the people at Netflix stain remember
they have all their metrics going well
you got 27 minutes well I'm trying to
but I wouldn't necessarily come out with
my strongest thing yeah so if i do
another one I'm gonna think ahead of
time right that that audience can get up
and leave and go yeah so how do you just
grab them keep them thank you go yeah
you can't waste time no even though in
the ether now with me being old-school
just by the notion of my age the TED
talk with jokes what i call ted talk
with jokes right is fine and that is
this other style of really revealing
personal things right if it's kind of
funny which i think is born from social
media where it is all about knowing Tom
behind the curtain right like like this
yeah this this could be your special
right you know I can help people sell no
more and be / I mean you're kind of your
sort of well you're younger than
my generate you're a step down in a
sense like your peers would be bill burr
and Louie right yeah yeah but I'm
definitely more in the vein of a little
more joke heavy well I still I still
think the hardest thing to do is to
really end and make an audience laughs
for an hour straight it's a long time
yeah and hours for anybody I mean I am I
excited that your specials coming out up
I won't make it through oh no I I don't
mind fell Chris Rock whoever it's just
like no yeah I long 20 you make it 15 20
would be the perfect stand-up special I
agree if you could cut your thing into
three twenties and release them over
three months I I totally agree and
netflix has it has a very open-ended
policy toward length gym referees just
did one that was 85 uh-huh but I wonder
if they would let me do that let me just
shoot three specials I mean for cost
yeah but you know it would be grey
minutes is about about fine because
that's when you could kind of lean into
it and have it be an extended laughs yes
um before everything has to deflate for
a second especially 40 minutes you know
that they have to kind of you know yeah
and then you have to rebuild that's
right because even if you if you build
it where you for 40 minutes they are
really laughing hard yeah this is a
great act yeah just physically they need
a break yeah they need to just okay let
my face kind of back yeah babe let me
get catch my breath you have to kind of
reset it and then go from the next 20
and the other just it's sort of a thing
I have to deal with which is not a
complaint at all but like when I'm
playing the first thing I said to the
producer of the special i said i'd like
to play not to my audience uh-huh i did
a talk for david spade's book and it was
david and i wasn't advertised so is
david's audience uh-huh and then I felt
better and killed harder and everything
was nicer when i play too exclusively my
audience they're a little older it's
like they've just watched my DVD from my
SNL yer the reg I totally understand so
it's Hotel California to that right and
then I'm not really doing that
right sometime not intentionally being
edgy but I'm doing stuff to amuse myself
yes a little outside what they're
expecting so I'm always dealing with
that a little bit right and it's a good
problem to have yeah that if I start to
go into the church lady or not gonna do
it it's like as the whole lines go saw
my wife was in the audience she goes
they love it though even when you just
change your voice yeah because i always
say i don't really have a face or a
voice like i am an invisible person i
can still walk around no one I mean I am
perfect to drop a nose on or a wig like
you could like I've said before you
could put two inches of prosthetic
makeup on Jon Lovitz and go hi John you
know so anyway that's something that is
interesting so for you you've done how
many specials now this will be my fourth
so this would probably be the sweet spot
because the people coming will have kind
of basically just watch your last three
right o your evolution as you they've
been with you right but so for me I
disappear for 10 years I tend to take 10
to 12 years off at a time and then I got
back yeah here's me sorry that's just
another thing that was kind of scene but
the audience was doing is interesting
thing to think about and I kind of I
kind of try not to think about it
because of going after the the
audience's my audience you know it's a
lot of families it's a lot of couples
and you know just as the culture resets
you think well I should be talking to my
nephews who are like 22 right like
that's the next generation of people are
going to come out and buy tickets and do
all right it's like I should try and get
them but then it's like like what how
you know why yeah i see i might the to
Millennials are with me now my son's
okay and so they were going you should
totally do that Dad whenever we're
driving in the the Icehouse away right
and i'm going off you know the resume yo
yeah totally so they were the ones
pushing me to do other stuff your stuff
right yeah right do you still use voices
if they're not your iconic voices
totally i use them just all the time you
do use them all yeah all the time and
was that the beginning when you said
like Howard Cosell was in your pocket
that the first open mic was her voice is
always a yes and was it a thing
as a as a child like you were doing a
family yeah John John Wayne I did lyndon
johnson I you know I had the little tape
recorder the Craig real the real i was
recording johnson winners well all the
basic stuff so Dom but was introverted
incredibly introverted never took
theatre arts was just was running
running running during the running boom
running right mile the two-mile running
in junior college and the friends I made
running is what that that's what made me
decide to do it but the voices were
always something that I did you know
yeah and you feel like do you feel like
that's more of a an actor head than a
comedian head you know cuz you're going
for laughter you know yeah but there's
like that thing like I started out
acting and sometimes I feel like
disappearing into a role is almost
easier than telling people exactly who I
am you know what I mean like I still
haven't figured out exactly who I am
yeah and if I can get into a role it's
just so relaxing and easy can just the
voice changes a little bit you do that
kind of thing yeah is the impression
thing more of an actor thing or a
comedian thing well I would say it's
more of an actor thing and I think that
I was always a sketch player in my heart
right well up in San Francisco there
wasn't there was some sketch people
going around ducks breath mystery
theater and stuff but i never once I got
in the stand up I just did stand-up and
of course Robin would come back and
forth right and he was doing you know
Shakespeare and theatrical stuff right I
tried to be him for a few years right I
realize I can't be him and I eventually
start develop my own style the first
time because i was playing bars you know
show us your dick you know yeah so Jimmy
Stewart swearing would get me through
the blender going but I was always
trying to do sketch I think and you know
when I got to the other cafe this little
dive ADC thing in the haight ashbury
yeah I finally said I'll coming to be a
character because I didn't characters to
like research lady came from that I'm
gonna be a character around 45 seconds
which terrified me yeah but I started
there by the time I got in SNL in 86 I'd
never done sketch comedy formally and so
when when I got on the show and started
doing it was really weird like people
were talking at me because normally i
play both characters right or when I got
a laugh I wanted to look at the audience
right you know yet so i think i was
always a sketch player and i think that
for me once you have a wife and children
and brothers and sisters if you want to
be just completely prostrate yourself
with honesty right you can you know
you're already it's a it's it's it's a
show yeah I mean you're you're already
editing edges and things you know I want
to bury that person don't wanna hurt
that person so yeah I mean for me just
to complete the thought that made me so
excited in my twenties was Monty Python
or Andy Kaufman Peter Sellers stuff that
I could hear multiple times rhythms yeah
that we are the knights who say neat or
there some spam minute so those rhythmic
things and that's what I did right with
my friends that why would ask you like
as i was born in the back of the
Volkswagen bug as a comic with my friend
stoned was the last person to smoke pot
ray and I would do 20 minutes of Star
Trek or 10 minutes of the water polo
coach but nothing was short form
observational bits right it was winding
down so when you first realize you were
funny right where was that and what what
were you doing you making your mom
laughs or you yeah it was bright as my
parents it was it was my parents
actually the first time ever that I
actually like went in front of people to
do it like I do voices in home I would
do I would have it to Rosanna ok then
adana day yeah yeah yeahs stuff and I
was doing little voices and I went up on
in second grade I went in front of the
class with a banana peel and it was just
like lunch was winding down were all
saying no one asked me to go yeah I
don't know what I was thinking I just
got my banana peel I went up to the
front of the class and started twirling
it around singing a rhinestone cowboy
but making it rhinestone banana ok all
rights don't banana and just shook my
hips and goddamn laughs now a teacher
sent me back right I just remember
sitting there like
tried I just done a bit like yeah lot of
people that was it just totally her plan
yeah and then you know this does through
the years just kind of would always be
like voices and my kind of thing with
your friends yeah that that was
basically it so you know I think that in
its purest form and I've met the people
are sort of in the purest form it is
sort of like an attorney like a like
prosecuting attorney right being very
honest with a very strong singular point
of view right usually in a very
complaining mode or disenfranchised mark
and you know often say the comedians who
get into that style of being angry and
then after success then they have to
shore up the angry exec you know a
muhfuckas album [ __ ] driving me crazy
you know really seriously you know I
always say there you know some of the
commune's of my generation now they're
in their 50s and they're still doing
masturbation jokes I'm a size 10 mais
totally jacked off I think well no you
didn't yes first of all you don't have
the physical fitness you don't have the
hormonal balance to just do that three
times a day yeah and the other by the
angry comedian and then sort of yeah the
mayors of comedy real mention them but
the ones who are really upset if it's
not done properly right right and just
hate carrot top right except like spent
a lot of energy thinking about you know
I just look at it we're all clowns yeah
um I've always thought the same way it's
like we're so he's getting laughs with a
different way with different people who
cares yeah that are bent over in pain
their brains are full of endorphins
we've got to stop this man at right you
know uh you know yeah so but when you
before so now came up though and you're
out there and you're you're doing your
stand-up and your kind of figuring it
out was SNL always like that's got
that's the spot I mean that's the sketch
landing pad yeah because there wasn't
really like we your eyes really on that
or are you thinking maybe I'll just do
this act on my own I miss my wife and I
been together since 79 and I asked her
did I ever talk about being rich and
famous you know never interesting I was
really thinking trying to
get to be the middle act right and I was
they because they were looking for
bodies I was headlining before I had any
business headlining oh I got a guitar
and props and Bray I got all this stuff
and then I just was sort of thinking
like that SNL was so abstract I it just
seemed you know I had two tracks which
is very unusual it's very long story but
basically NBC saw me in 1979 or 80 just
do a set in San Francisco and sign me to
a deal right now that was based on just
being an innocent Disney faced character
they didn't want me to be funny right I
was cast as Mickey ruin his grandson in
the show took place in New York I've
never done any acting anything I was
terrible and Nathan Lane was the other
guy with me my roommate and then we had
Mickey Rooney and we ended up on the
sixth floor Rockefeller Center and I'm
living in New York City 25 or 26 i would
go upstairs on thursdays watch Joe
Piscopo and Eddie Murphy rehearse she's
thinking well this would be cool yeah
you know and I would do Andy Rooney
impressions for my makeup artist who
also worked on Sarah Night Live and it
would tell Joe Piscopo there's this kid
on the Mickey Rooney show but the very
first day of rehearsal Mickey pointed me
and said you're the straight man some
really yeah after four years in the
club's he say back as a mean guy oh yeah
you're the straight man he had a 38
revolver eid wave around they're not
gonna get me no I was the number one
store in the world hear me bang the
world and he said it exactly like that
10,000 times real one starring well you
hear me and he married like 20 times
right oh yeah aight time it right he was
a kind of guy you just he'd be at the
piano playing chords this is stefan
sauce on himes favorite song I wrote it
no and he was my he thought I was gay
and liked it and he would put his arm
around Nathan Nathan I had to hide this
from Mickey right so he put his arm
around Nathan this is true and looked at
me and said I'm just glad we like girls
and he pointed at me with his arm around
Nathan so the whole thing was crazy and
then I you would like what the hell is
happening what is I know and so I was
doing clubs I back
canceled like everything else and I kept
getting side things I was on I did a
pilot with Desi Arnaz jr. I was kind of
the straight man right where we were
bombing halfway through Lucille Ball
grab the mic from the warm up and
started yelling at the audience what's
wrong with you people this is funny no
as its looked really disappointed went
in the back got a b12 shot that nice I
don't I did yeah what Blue Thunder with
James Farentino I was in a little helmet
and I see were just adore my lines were
like I'm jamming I'm jamming you know
check the radar i'll check it I got
fired from all those shows and then SNL
came around freakily so six years later
from being in there at doing one of the
boys right I was then i went up to 8 h
took me six years ago and where they
find you to take you up well I'd
audition two or three times before I
audition up fruits SNL right just cuz in
big cattle calls like right I followed
Kennison at midnight at the comedy store
oh just death wasn't that special just
[ __ ] I was your audition yeah five
minutes no MC just one after the other
Kennison levitated the room and no
introduction and just I went up oh just
death so I just thought I was 31 I just
thought it's over I'm never happy on SNL
yeah came around again freakily and I'd
spent two years really really doing a
lot of stand-up right so I was in the
best shape for stand-up ever and rum
Lorne Michaels will see you come some of
his lieutenant saw me at the comedy
magic club right I said I'm not going to
at the improv comedy store do it at eb's
on the west side 100 seat theater Rosie
O'Donnell was headlining there I asked
her I'd never met her could I come in
she said yes so I did 40 with a real
audience Wow the most almost the most
nervous I've ever been and Lauren came
in right right as I was about to go up
Lorne Michaels brandon tartikoff the
head of NBC at the time and share and
I'm just nobody side this is my shot
this is my choice this is my life this
is it and I was good enough in the
audience was normal I didn't have to do
five minutes right can I had I had shot
broccoli in my back pocket I had church
lady I had a few impressions and that's
basically there was other auditions
basically church lady church lady and I
didn't eat I did Jimmy Stewart I did
Casey Kasem right robin Leach I did um
you know I did this little breeze
character I just saw that you used a lot
that i use the first season yeah yeah
yeah wow so do they you do your set goes
well 40 minutes did well enough do
they'll eat just leave really talk to
you know I talked to him on the sidewalk
a little bit and then I met with him a
few days later where I met Jon Lovitz
and Phil Hartman right and Lauren wants
to see you and just went in you know the
Dana um you know sometimes I won't hire
someone because I don't like their shoes
you know I mean a very intimidating
character literally but my time there
ended up being very fair you know just
fantastic because lady was the last
sketch and the rehearsal show my very
first show and got moved up to the first
sketch and and really did well but I'd
honed it in clubs for two years but
never put the dress on so then I was off
to a good start and it really lifted the
show and having fill in jan play
supporting characters because they were
real superstar sketch players yeah that
good as it gets yeah and they played
Tammy Faye bait and all that so so
online kid you yeah it is so great
though I mean it was such you know as a
fan of the show for so long and is he
had the dips and things and came back
when you guys were hitting it it was
just like this great great great era and
it just felt like did you click with
those guys right away did you guys yeah
you just I like I'm bill on John right
away that we were the last small cast it
was Phil and John and I were basically
the main players and then we had Kevin
Nealon Dennis Miller rom and we just had
three women Nora Dunn and Jan hooks and
victoria jackson right so i click with
him right away like them both a lot and
it took us a while to kind of gel but we
were just gentle and I I often thought
SNL people should be like big badass
pirate men right as dan Aykroyd just
seemed a badass her Bill Murray might
make you laugh or beat you up right
Chevy Chase is 65 I mean I just thought
me really I mean
closest to me physically was Martin
Short I toured as a performer yeah but I
just thought really and they said if we
don't hit the ground running were
cancelled she's I thought I maybe that
thou may be the ones to take it to that
whole thing was like a dream mad
reviewing that uh if you would met Phil
in John and just you hated them yeah
just like one of those people you can't
be funny around if you know think they
were greeted generating all day long
they just did the gangster thing that's
all four months before you know where's
our that 30s voice what's the wet on the
street what do you say pal what are you
doing how you doing down we you know
people said is that all they do but
they've been The Groundlings together
but they we but some of my favorite
stuff later on i did with phil the
carson thing i loved ya doing that with
him and god yeah so good he seemed like
such such like a perfect soul like
everybody just you could just seen that
guy's eyes people just you just fell in
love with him you saw that he knew it
was brilliant but there was like this
kindness to him yeah he just naturally
he's one of those performers like when
he passed everybody took it personally
you know it's kind of a Robin thing it
was like yeah at a different level than
just a guy you saw on TV yeah phil was
so gifted you know as an artist and
musician and he was so renaissance man
you know and he it's almost like what do
you want to do he'll be the lead in the
sketch he'll be the supporting player
but he didn't really care about the fame
or trying to be the top thing yeah
because he could do it so effortlessly
and you know i mean i always I've told
the story before but you know the middle
the night on tues we were trying to
write the show and mostly offices are
like a you know world war three dumpster
it means [ __ ] everywhere and everyone's
exhausted and I'm walking down the
offices seeing these scraggly writers
burnt out and I go down to Phil's office
and it's immaculate and he's got an
easel and he's painting painting a
sailboat that's very Phil oh yeah
perfect yeah he's so lucky so when you
go after that show in the success is
beyond with it yeah just crazy back to
AZ especially wayne's world was the
topic oh it's george bush oh it was just
insane and then the films and stuff what
is happening to your act at this point
are you
even going up on stage we doing
appearances are you doing corporate gig
yeah you are I do a mix of all of them I
because i'm still doing some of my kids
no I mean no I mean during that period
like oh you know what I'm doing this all
gets danapur yeah I'm and then come back
to ya yeah I would tour I would do some
dates during the summer uh-huh College
is mostly in some dates but during the
that was nine months now right i was
just not doing it my money kept going up
in my act kept going down I go wow I'm
really not in shape right now I am
terrible stand up but i'm getting paid
50 times as much right you know how
great it must have been such a great
feeling when those first times after its
hit and you go on stage in the audience
really wants to see you right from all
those years of like I'm fighting it used
to take me the entire hour to get them
on my side right you know and then
barely toward the end you working and
fighting I don't know I would never know
how to describe it except that um even
for me in my little tiny way I had this
woman just used to do some massage on me
in Malibu and my wife and I live there
and she also at a period of time did Bob
Dylan loose comparison but you said that
bob was just a dude yeah that he'd never
caught up to his fame you know right and
what happened to me just from where I
came this middle class family no one
ever been in show business yeah actually
being in show business to making a
living in show business to headlining
comedy clubs you have actually been on
television and then being on television
be non sarà Night Live and then actually
having it go really really well and then
getting really really rich it's just so
real I mean sir really surreal really I
mean I think anybody cuz now i'm back
with my sons and their friends and you
get back in touch with their sink am I
going to do this right is this how I'm
gonna make a living I could have a
career like Jerry Seinfeld yeah or or
this career this guy do headlining clubs
makes 60 grand a year ago 40 grand okay
so they're just so their eyes are big
about that so they're both how old are
they 22 and 24 and they
both won their doings they're doing
sanam they started without me the one
out i didn't dart did it up together so
no separate separate yeah just loved it
wanted to do love it love all everything
love doing digital videos love were they
acting were they always funny really
funny kids yeah yeah they're really I
mean they helped me a lot there um they
know exactly when I've had a good show
right they know when I was connected
they know that that little ad lib
they'll pick it out right oh the
sensibility is just right in sync with
me like I said they push me to do edgier
edge of your stuff is such a it's gotta
be so fun I mean I've two kids were
smaller and you know they're funny in
their own way like you see like that she
might be yeah how many funny she might
be comedian funny but tend to like have
these guys it must be weird for you to
watch them well this is this is sir as
surreal yeah as my my sons are now young
men working with me and we're on the
road together and we go into a comedy
club and in its core it's kind of the
same yeah except they're with me and
then i'm watching to do stand-up
sometimes it's not going so well so i
have to leave the show room of course um
that just as surreal as as getting on
Sarah Night Live and becoming a
professional right it's all completely I
don't even know what to say such a weird
path isn't it it's I I just but you know
the the interesting thing to me that
because of social media and all the
tools and technology a lot of their
friends went and got Liberal Arts
degrees in college but now they just
want to do they want to be in show
business right now because being good
doesn't matter as much as it used to
that's why I have to slow them down
right you can be a surrogate boyfriend
you know just going hey gang and make
three four thousand years so yeah it's
up ended so so many parents I talked to
their kid is either with some kind of
media start up for some right podcast
thing that might go there or some girls
just do it young woman's even stand up
of the club but she's instagramming it
and the whole experience so a lot of
people
be in show business and if you look at
it that way rather than when I came up
where you were constantly asking for
permission to do it yeah now you can do
it can just do it you know where is your
feature film where's my feature film the
camcorder edited on our laptop yeah so
so it I told my wife look I can't say
that they're gonna be famous or wealthy
but I faces work hard they'll make as
much as a guy works for a UPS driver
wreck it's 90 grand a year with benefits
yeah and so or and they could do much
much better than that but but i think
it's not as exotic when you set out do
your parents roll their eyes a little
bit your tongue yeah just like what are
you doing what yeah my dad was like oh
my son's gonna be a comedian Jesus
Christ isn't the big dummy you know it
was just like so I'm gonna be the
president I'm lorae an astronaut no no
it's amazing i watch my kids and their
friends are like they're all day is
about accumulating content for their
Instagram or their snapchat or they're
they're like yeah they're producing
their editing they're doing all this
stuff yeah its crew you can have a
career inside out so to speak you can
build it in the other way you can be
famous more quickly you can be famous on
a YouTube level have you know aliens of
kids watching you but not really have an
act yet we have to think and you'll get
really famous I mean it probably your
listeners know this and then they want
to put you in the club so they
frantically try to get an act yeah but
that there is no shortcut there i mean
you can take a five-year-old put them on
in a film say your dog died and they
will get nominated for an Oscar yeah you
can't put any human being on a stage
their first time and have them do a hot
tight hour which is what I love about it
yes not to change no the algorithm has
not been invented to supplant us nope
and it's remarkably the same at ed at
its core it really which is when
everything else is upended well I have
to say their toes is hit the tunnels
it's been so interesting I get out you
were five hour now I guess you got to
talk to somebody else or something
anyway well this was really really
interesting so great found it
interesting I hope your I could meet
now of course they yeah now how could
they not your Athena Carvey we're
talking about the whole year through the
real stuff yeah well I'll just do a
little is fearlessness is my new toy you
know and you start down here if you want
to do Trump you just go disasters the
total disaster total disaster okay okay
okay okay total disaster so that you
know those things are just I just
abstract them and abstract that oh I
can't I keep amused it's so crazy i mean
therapy it's frank gorshin were you fana
from of course my god because Burke
Douglas and Burt Lancaster his were
brilliant I did a movie with them by the
way you did I did because to me and I'm
opening up something that's they're
telling yeah but this is we could talk
for an hour about this will come back
why another Frank Gorshin he him in you
whatever grammar i'm using at that point
uh we're able to just take those those
little kernels and make them into such
identifiers that nobody else was doing
about these people and that's why you're
here asians just really lasted in
Gorshin yeah poured himself a new the
same kind of thing and jim carrey the
physicality i think i put you carry you
know one day I was the I he just made
Bruce turns face yeah it was like
serious and ready because Jim Carrey's
he's engorgement they definitely have a
symbiotic thing I don't know I think
part of it i don't think i have the ear
of kevin Pollak or frank caliendo huh
their ears are just that this up so i
just abstract them but i'm always trying
to keep myself amused yeah you know i'd
like to do this but he goes okay okay
okay so I'm just taking that but somehow
it works already okay is express and so
that makes my produce oh great do you
want so much fun really fun we have to
come back at some point oh you know we
haven't even plugged what you're here to
plug oh gosh your life of pets secret
life with pets I play a dog I do the
grumpy old man is the dog it's you can I
get out of here i'm a grumpy old dog has
paralyzed legs and it's the only movie
my kids want to see this summer I know
I've never been in a movie that everyone
knows you I've never seen press like
this yeah yeah your life of pets it's
coming out friday it looks really funny
it's really it's very funny Louie CK
Kevin Hart yes they're so great well
thank you so much i would love to have
you back since i will do it are
absolutely everybody thank you for
listening we'll see you next time enjoy
your life
for your life for your life for your
life for your life for your life for
your life for your life for your life
for your life